normally when you pip install a python
package it will download from pi pi the
python package index but did you know
you can actually pip install directly
from github
take the git url to your favorite
project and add git plus in front then
you can just pip install it to try out
the latest commit from that repo
you can also add an at sign with a git
reference such as a branch tag name
commit hash or pull request number to
install a specific version
this can be useful for testing versions
of packages that haven't been officially
published yet like from a feature branch
or pull request it's good practice to
also specify the egg name which is what
pip will treat this project's name as
for the purposes of dependency checking
so if you later install another package
that depends on the github one it will
know it's already installed all this
only works if the repo is an actual
python package with a setup.pi file not
just a lonely script check out my video
on automated testing if you want to see
how to set that up if the setup.pi isn't
at the root of the repo you can specify
it with the subdirectory query parameter
in the url